right so can I record yes okay yeah hi
guys it's so I can't I can't do it yes
hi guys and again we'll just pretend
that never happened and that's one of my
earlier intros there yeah you you don't
you don't have no idea what I'm working
on right now because like I said I'm
working like four episodes ahead
but right now I'm making the free by
coaster the I say the free fly coaster
even though at this point nobody knows
about it
and I got a douche it's on a rock work
just like you did Sandler with your
amazing horrible issue yet no [ __ ]
idea we're placing it
I actually like doing rock work no it's
fun first time but that's for a while it
gets really really well irritating
because every time you face a rock you
can see where it's place that's why I
make a general layout first but I don't
know it's something that I don't really
need my mind for and which is usually
something that's good for me because I'm
an idiot and I never think of what I
built so then I end up with stupid stuff
and I need to redo I'm sorry guys but
epic plot twists silver I actually
frickin hates Sanders work so much LA
and he's just sugarcoating everything
he's saying guys my boys sugarcoat
everything I say my entire life is a lie
basically I hate all of my subscribers
they're all stupid I'm at opposite
Hideaway and sander is a total noob and
what else in Panda is supreme race filth
you know
filthy no-limits peasants rollercoaster
three master race for the win right now
I'm actually failing to find the Roxette
that I was using so I'm very incompetent
see this is what happened this is what
happens if I try to talk and do things
at the same time I just mess up
bye guys panda coasters
reason number so decisions to the P
my song isn't me through the beach
see
so all the tasks at hand have been
cleared now meaning guards all the rock
work is done and sports are done as well
except for this little part that I may
or may not finish because I might as
well finish cover it up with foliage but
I'm probably going to finish it anyway
because
sometimes my voice really annoys me and
that's pretty much it so the next thing
to do is the foliage of course and I'll
do that next episode so see you know